if you've lived in the area for a while
well you've probably heard of the
northern nevada railway that's right
it's about four hours north of us up in
ely boy this train chugs along it's a
100 plus year old steam engine that
powers out into the desert to one of the
darkest areas in north america it can be
so dark you can barely see your hand in
front of your face but that means that
the stars shine bright
brightly out there in the sky the
popular star train it sells out a year
in advance but you have the chance to
take a similar ride complete with a
glass of bubbly champagne mark bassett
the president of northern nevada railway
is live this morning to talk more about
it thank you mark so nice to meet you
and thanks for being here it's the new
sunset stars and champagne ride so mark
tell us all about it it sounds wonderful
i'd be very happy to do that it is a
wonderful trip
we're taking advantage of our dark skies
it uh we are an hour away from great
basin national park and that is an
international dark sky park
and
because of that we started the sunset
stars and champagne train
where we depart the depot at 7 pm we
watch the sun go down we serve a glass
of bubbly
and then as the sun goes down the stars
pop out for just a wonderful experience
it is a slow train ride we're not in any
sort of hurry
so how long does the train lie ride last
and how much does uh this one cost i
i've tried to do the star train every
time i go on the site i can never get a
reservation it's sold out so much in
advance so what's the what what's the
price of this one and how long does it
last
the price of this one is 56
for adults and it lasts about two and a
half hours oh it sounds great now these
are just summer nights that you're doing
the champagne ride is that right that is
correct uh the last one is mid-september
we do them thursday night and saturday
night
okay and i can imagine these are quite
popular as well as all of your train
rides are what is it about the nostalgia
of riding the train and being out in the
middle of nowhere what is it that people
love about these train rides
it's at this time stopped here it's been
said the employees went to lunch and
just never came back
we have the original buildings the
original locomotives the original
paperwork dating back to 1906
and it's just an opportunity to
experience
what america what grew america and that
was our railroads
and i think it being the international
designated dark sky up there makes it
phenomenal we've got the perseids meteor
shower right now which would be a great
time to go up and ride the train
just quickly go over some of the other
train rides you have a lot of holiday
specialty rides as well
we do we have our haunted ghost trains
in october where you might see a ufo or
bigfoot
we have santa's reindeer flyer as our
christmas train and that runs from
thanksgiving to christmas
and then during the summer months we
also have
a rocking and rolling train and that is
our geology train and then also for the
century after the roaring 20s we do the
roaring 20s train too and that goes back
a century
oh my gosh mark it is so wonderful it
just it it takes everybody back to a
time that probably well most of us have
never lived through so
that's what's so fun about it and it's
just quite beautiful and we thank you so
much for spending time with us this
morning we'll have the link on our
website 8newsnow.com if people want to
log on and get tickets you still have
room right for the stars sunset and
champagne rides we still have some room
yes we do okay all right thanks so much
i think i think your video froze but boy
all those pictures and video of the
train rides are fantastic thank you mark
bassett oh my gosh nate
john
have you ever done that ride yes we've
been on the ghost ride oh the ghost so
how is it it is so fun because there are
special guests that are with you on the
train that you don't know are there when
you get on board okay then the lights go
down and you're out in the middle of
nowhere and then suddenly there's some
stuff going on
i would say it's great and it's not that
far away it's up in ely so it's about
three hours
away okay yeah it's not that bad but you
know the star train rides those book out
a year in advance and i i'm not kidding
i can never get on one because they're
sold out so you have to do that early
you gotta get mark on it you gotta yeah
gotta have an inside track so to speak
to get those tickets but i really would
like to do the champagne ride for sure
wonderful
go for it thursday night tonight yeah
thursdays and saturdays if we leave now
we can make it yeah we're going to catch
our train and even have lunch before the
ride